all right guys
bang bang i've got brad from unstoppable
domains here
welcome back thank you so much for doing
this sir thanks much for having me
absolutely i feel like you guys have
been absolutely crushing it you guys
have been launching all kinds of new
things
uh for those that haven't listened to
the previous episode give us a quick
overview of just what is unstoppable
domains
yeah for sure so we are building domain
names
on blockchains it's dns on the
blockchain
and what we've built is uh domain
registries
uh similar to like.coms except for that
they are
smart contracts on a blockchain so
domains are stored inside of your wallet
instead of sitting on godaddy or
something else like that so
nobody else can move the domain around
nobody can take the domain away from you
unstoppable domains can't even take the
domain away from you or turn it off or
anything like that
and we've also built kind of like a
godaddy for the blockchain where you
can find domains you can buy domains you
can manage domains and you can build
websites all from unstoppabledomains.com
so that's what we're building tools to
make it easier for people to
use the decentralized web absolutely and
so when people hear decentralized web i
think they'll go
oh what's that like maybe i've heard the
term before i have no clue what that
actually means
describe a little bit about the
difference between a centralized web and
a decentralized web
users are in control in the
decentralized web it's exactly the same
thing
as what happens with crypto uh with
crypto users are in control of your
money
in traditional finance banks and
financial institutions are in control of
your money
so the same thing is true for your
domain names
and for your web content so your domain
names in the traditional world
are part of a centralized database
dns servers they're controlled by a
whole bunch of different
parties but essentially effectively
controlled by
a group that's heavily heavily
influenced by the us government
and they're able to move domains around
turn domains off
there they essentially have custody of
the domains for you
blockchain domains you have them you
control them they're stored inside of
your wallet just like a cryptocurrency
and then on the web hosting side in the
traditional world you are storing your
content on amazon web services or some
other
some other service like that and here
you're storing your content on a
decentralized storage network
like ipfs filecoin something like that
and so the net effect of all of this
is when i have my domain plus i have my
hosted content on a decentralized
network
i now have a website that only i can put
up or take down i now have complete
control of my data
this is the opposite of the way the
traditional web works
and when you hear all of this kind of
crazy stuff about what's going on with
facebook and all the controversies
all of it tends to come down to this one
key point which
is these companies control your data you
don't control your data
and as a result of that we are not the
customer of facebook we are the product
of facebook
the customer are the companies that are
buying our data
if in the future world when we have a
future when we have a decentralized web
you're going to control your data and
then you'll be the customer
of a future facebook and you'll give
them permission to
use some of your data in order to
provide you a service but you'll control
your social network
you'll can you'll control all of your
data and you'll be able to move around
with that
it'll be interoperable you'll be able to
use your your social graph inside of 50
applications
completely different than the way that
the the current web works and it all
comes
comes down to this one simple idea users
do not have property rights on the
internet
uh you have property rights in the real
world but for some reason
when we went when we moved things onto
the internet it all of a sudden became
legal and okay
for companies to just take everything
take everything from you
uh you would never allow allow a company
to walk inside of your house and take
your stuff that's what you're doing
online right now
and so as you kind of go into this world
there's obviously the domains for
websites and things to be hosted
information but
the part to me that's so interesting is
you can also use these domains now
um you know coinbase wallets right you
guys have run ads kind of everywhere
telling people that coinbase wallets
uh now support these unstoppable domains
as the recipient of funds so i no longer
will send somebody a bitcoin wallet
address
i now instead can send pomp.crypto and
all of a sudden somebody can actually
send me bitcoin to that wallet address
describe a little bit about
kind of the multiple use cases of these
domains
so the way to think about it is that a
blockchain domain
you can write any information that you
want to it because you control it so
it's far more flexible than a
traditional domain
and what's going to wind up happening is
is that in the traditional world you've
got
a venmo account and a paypal account
with a username and then you've got
your website and then you've got maybe
your
you know facebook username or your
whatsapp username or whatever else
you're using
for messaging all of these are different
systems all with different usernames
that none of them interoperate uh with
the blockchain domain you can just have
one thing
so you can just have pomp.crypto someone
can send you money
someone can also visit your website
someone can also send you an encrypted
message
and because it's all to the same thing
you now have this increased
security you have this decreased risk of
an imposter
i know that when i am
messaging with you that i'm also paying
to the same person
i know if i'm visiting your website and
i send money to pom.crypto
i'm sending to the same person that
controls that website so
it's kind of a it's kind of a weird idea
for people that a domain name can also
be your
your you know like kind of like your
decentralized venmo account
uh but it can uh and that's the first
use case that the crypto community has
been using so you mentioned coinbase
wallet
works in a couple dozen other wallets
works for about 100 different currencies
so if you have 100 different crypto
addresses
you can attach them all to this one
domain tell somebody
they can type that in pay you in any of
the currencies you support
absolutely and so like how does this uh
change crypto payments like what is the
future look like we saw with the
centralized internet there used to be ip
addresses you kind of had to remember
all the numbers and the sequence
then we got human readable urls that
changed everything
is the same thing going to happen here
when it comes to bitcoin and crypto
payments with these kind of
human readable domains absolutely it's
so
hard you you can't even imagine
onboarding onboarding new people when
you have to explain this idea of you got
these
not only do you have a 20 character
address and a 40 character address
you've got dozens of them
so right now sometimes people will send
you an email you know with you know a
list of you know 10 different addresses
to send to that just does not
it does not at all appear like the way
that
your future payments are going to work
it's not the way the current payments
work if you look at the way it works
right
now bimbo is great you search for a name
of somebody that you want to pay you see
their picture maybe you see some social
information in order to verify it's the
right person
then you click and send like that's the
experience that ultimately we're going
to need in crypto in order to be able to
compete
absolutely and i guess as this becomes
more pervasive and people realize that
you can do this
it also changes the types of payments
that people look for right
it's really hard right now to kind of
take that bitcoin wallet address or
crypto wallet address
and just like display it on your website
for example right but if now all of a
sudden you can simply put in a social
media message and say hey
send it to pom.crypto it complete game
changer in the way that you use it i
think that maybe one of the proxies
people have done is used qr codes
right it's kind of a way to do it maybe
talk a little bit about
not only the sender having their
activity change but also the people who
now
can accept kind of donations or payments
in a whole different way using these
human readable domains
so you could imagine a campaign where
somebody
uh tries to do a fundraising campaign
and essentially
the domain itself the payment address
can go viral
like so right now you have to say okay
um
you know here's a cause that i really
care about everybody you know click on
this link read this description
go through these payment details here's
a here's a credit card section put in
all your information oh what about your
billing address and you go through all
of these different
steps and then eventually you can
support that
that campaign uh here you can say
hey you know pay to you know feed the
children.crypto or whatever i don't know
if that's a
live domain so don't try that um but
something like that
uh and then you could just share that on
the internet and say hey
hey everybody you know do you support
this cause um
send money to you know this and that's
the only information
that people need to know so i think
there's a there's a future
where we're going to have viral donation
campaigns because it's just
so low friction in order to be able to
participate
yeah and to me the part that becomes
really interesting not only is one can
they go viral but two
uh it's i call it memeable right meaning
that like i can remember pomp.crypto if
i say it enough times everyone will
remember it
you can imagine that happening also for
whether it's uh celebrities large
businesses
nonprofits just you kind of go down the
line
you can really see that the domain
itself becomes part of that marketing
message right it becomes
you know the meme is the message and
there's nothing better than actually the
address itself um kind of going out and
we saw in the late 90s
with like every company being com like
what better name than to have your
website as your name
right i think here's something similar
is happening right
absolutely yeah um you guys also have
launched
this twitter verification or kind of
real world ids
uh i don't think people even understand
the problem um so let's start there kind
of like what problem you saw around
identification um as you guys were
building
so just imagine for a moment someone
says hey
you know send me you know a hundred
thousand dollars for
some business transaction now imagine
that they say
okay send it to this anonymous random
string of numbers and letters
and hope that it gets to you know hope
that this money gets to me i mean we've
all had this
you know this feeling of you know i'm i
type in the address
i check it i triple check it maybe i do
a test transaction
uh i panic for an extra 30 seconds and
then finally i
i will myself to press the button that's
the current experience that we have with
crypto payments
that is very different than how it works
with venmo with venmo i don't do any of
those things
even if i want to send my friend two
thousand dollars i go
i find their username i see their
picture i can verify
some piece of social information about
them if they've linked it i feel pretty
confident
i'm paying the right person then i press
set um
and so there's all of this context that
we get in order to be able to
send money in the traditional world and
none of that exists in the crypto world
yet
so what we did is we said okay well
what's information that would be useful
for people
before they send money to somebody and
one thing that we thought was uh
verification of your twitter account so
what you're doing is is you're
attaching your twitter handle to a
crypto address
and you're doing this in a you know
relatively secure way
you're using oracles that go and
verify they all go and check the
blockchain and
check twitter uh to verify that it's the
same person that controls the domain
name
is the same person that controls the
twitter account but the net effect of
this is
if i go and type if you go and verify
pump dot crypto
when i go to pay you i can see the
twitter handle before i pay
and so then i can click it and i can
verify and i can say okay um
this is this is definitely the right
person before i'm sending money
and so if you think about the types of
people that are going to be wanting to
receive crypto uh for their businesses
you know it's going to be uh people who
are already public
in this way for the most part and so
this is a great way for them to
add more verification um twitter handle
is just one thing
but the nice thing about twitter handles
is that they are they're they're
relatively good pseudo-anonymous ids
because you have a lot of reputation
around them
because twitter platform is very secure
and very mature and so
you've got a lot of people who have you
know years of tweets and
followers and other things that you can
look at and you know scan and it takes
five seconds to say okay you know this
is
just the right person absolutely and
what's interesting to me about this
whole thing
is uh one using twitter as the
uh identification system um is
interesting but also
two is it starts to really eat away at
one of the problems which has
historically been
how do i one make sure that the uh the
the person or organization i'm sending
money to is gonna get it right so just
like the address itself is a pain in the
ass
but now too it's like end where it ends
up ends up being the person that i
actually intended it for
right so it's kind of like a two-step
thing that you guys are solving here
talk a little bit about kind of the
technology that you're using in order to
be able to
actually do this verification so what
people are doing is you're sending a
message with your private key that
controls the domain name
and you're writing your you're writing
the twitter handle
to the blockchain you're also tweeting
uh with like a with a code that matches
and then oracle's in the background
chain link or goals we use the the chain
link system in order to do this
uh we'll go and check the blockchain and
go
and check twitter and say do these
things match
and then they actually do a proof and
link that information to the blockchain
and if they all agree
then the the twitter handle is verified
and so the net effect of this is a
twitter handle
is associated with a specific crypto
address on the blockchain
got it and so when you're thinking about
other types of verification that could
potentially work
twitter's obviously a great one is it a
belief that like eventually you'll be
able to tap into like government
databases and use like licenses or
passports or or something like that
or maybe are there other kind of social
consensus almost type uh identifications
that may uh may be
valuable so i think you're you're going
in a couple of pretty cool directions
here
i think where this can end up is
ultimately what we're what you get from
a blockchain domain
is you get the user in control so the
when the user is in control the user
gets to decide what information is going
to be associated with it
it's not like a top-down you know
government id where they decide
everything and they control everything
you decide so you can actually decide i
want to be
completely anonymous and invisible i
want to be pseudo-anonymous and have
like a little bit of association
i want to be completely public but only
tied to my social ids
or i want to also have this you know
maybe i want this to be tied to my
government id
um you can have all of the above and so
what you can get is you can get kind of
like a bottom up
uh a bottom up view of who this person
is
if i tie three things together then that
makes you even more confident
that you know who i am if you tie a
government id
sure that can give you even more so i
think what you're going to wind up
getting in the blockchain world in
general is very similar to what you get
in the internet which is
all degrees of of usage
all the way from the completely private
to the completely public
and i think this is something that
people have still been wrestling with in
the crypto world
and if you if you you probably remember
this if you go back and you look at
you know memes on the internet from the
late 1990s
it's all about how you never know who
anyone is you could be like texting with
a dog or something like that in the
background
those were all the jokes that you
there's no idea on the internet it's
completely this crazy anonymous whatever
now the joke is there's too much idea on
the internet
facebook and everybody's completely
public so like if you fast forward 20
years
the experience that we're having with
the internet is almost completely the
opposite
of the impression that people had early
on and i think that what we can get from
the blockchain world
is a happy medium in users get to choose
users can go to the completely private
side of the spectrum users can go to the
completely public side of the spectrum
users can go anywhere in between and
we're not going to be forced
to go one way or the other because apps
won't control us
so user choice is going to lead to long
answer
user choice is going to lead to
absolutely every version of this
all the way from anonymous to government
id and everything in between
for sure and these oracles seem to be
kind of a really important piece of
infrastructure in doing this right the
connecting the
kind of real world data to these
blockchain based systems
how has the experience been in terms of
using oracles and
do you guys see kind of other use cases
in the product that you'll kind of
continue to use them for yeah and i
think that what's what's cool is that so
real um
oracles in general i think they've been
getting pretty popular over the past
year and for the most part they've been
uh grabbing financial data you know like
what's the price of bitcoin
uh or something like that so that you
can create derivative contracts or
whatever else you're trying to build
into your app you're trying to use
financial data for primarily for
financial services
that's great gigantic market but
uh there are there's this real world
information
that's going to be super interesting for
allowing users to do more things on the
decentralized web
and the twitter handle is just the first
step there there's a lot of other types
of real world
uh real world ids that can be used here
uh and so we definitely plan to
plan to add more for sure and as you
think through
kind of uh these domains you've got
one i can go and i can host things in
the decentralized web
i can do crypto payments are there other
products or kind of services that you
guys are thinking about as we look
forward to
to kind of what you guys could build it
seems like you kind of have these
different building blocks right you've
got the domain system you've got
obviously the exchange where you can go
and buy uh the domains you've got
this verification system now you've got
a pretty good understanding of oracle's
like it does feel like you're laying the
foundation to be able to build all kinds
of stuff i don't know if anything
there that is either top of mind or that
you guys are considering so there's a
bunch of different things that you need
on the internet but some of the the kind
of core components would be
you know you need payments uh you need
content which are websites
uh you need communication messaging um
those are three key components
and so the domains work for all of those
and so we're mostly mostly the way that
we build our roadmap
is to facilitate those use cases
so twitter verification is about
payments uh
making it more comfortable for you to be
able to send payments making it less
scary
to send payments so that's the idea
behind that the web tools that we've
been building
are around websites and content and then
we also built an early version of a chat
app
that is encrypted peer-to-peer chat app
where the domain name is the username so
no one can turn off your
can turn off your messages and it's not
sitting on any on any
company servers so all of the things
that you'll see us building
are going to be around facilitating
these these kind of core features on the
internet
um and the current internet provides us
with all three of those things payments
probably
you know they do not as good of a job at
maybe it's okay job now
that we have stripe and things like that
but for the most the history of the
internet payments was actually quite
being done quite poorly on the internet
so these are the core
features of the internet in general um
we
are just now building a decentralized
user control version of them
for sure and then help us understand
kind of
accessing this decentralized web because
i think there's a lot of people who say
oh decentralization that's going to
solve a lot of problems right
there's all kinds of things around
ownership and putting the user in charge
that you talked about
there's things around free speech like
there's just a lot of positive impact
from having a truly decentralized
internet
that people build on top of but then the
question i always get is like
how the hell do i access the
decentralized web right
they go to their chrome browser or
whatever and they start typing around
like ah everything looks centralized to
me so help people just have kind of a
101 of
how do they actually uh access that
decentralized web and where would you
send them
so right now i would send you to opera
browser for android
um that is the first place to support
uh native resolution of domain names so
if you go to opera for android you can
type in a dot crypto just like a dot com
and it works
there will be more soon there are
several browsers that are in various
phases
of working on this but what's going to
wind up happening is is that we're going
to have
a relatively small
but fully functioning alternate internet
where we're going to have
a handful of key browsers and other
applications where this stuff works
and it's not going to work natively
inside of chrome
or safari in the short term and we don't
expect that they're going to
jump on the decentralized web bandwagon
quickly
they're going to wait until there's a
whole bunch of users and until they have
to
but in the meantime we've got all of
these you know great alternative tools
that particularly the crypto community
is by and large already using
and then you can also use chrome
extensions and extensions in various
browsers
and is the thought process that uh it's
kind of a game theory
um where nobody jumps into the
decentralized web out of the major
players until there's enough users
and then once one does it everyone has
to follow but like everyone kind of like
looks around the room and says hey
nobody do it yet because then that means
we're all gonna have to go do it
but eventually that does uh that does
tip over well so i think we're in a
better place now than maybe we would
have been even a few years ago in the
browser world
where there's a bit more innovation now
there's
you know there's been brave browser
there's opera is actually trying to do a
lot of different stuff there's a lot of
alternative browsers that are on the
rise uh so there's a community
of applications that are pushing the web
the browser world forward
i think the the kind of big four
big three are going to wait because
browser is not their core business
so they don't have a reason to
innovate there unless they absolutely
have to
and so they will but they'll do it
when when it's time whereas these other
applications will do
it you know to help facilitate the
decentralized web because they need
uh they need strategies for the future
they need to be able to have they need
differentiation
uh in their markets but they also need
uh
they also need new market opportunities
you know they need some place to go
where the browser market has been a bit
stagnant now there's
there's energy uh towards this uh
towards this new world
and even separate from decentralized web
features they're also interested
in crypto in general and inter interac
and
integrating crypto wallets defy
applications things like that a browser
is a great place
to store your assets too have a wallet
in there so there's a bunch of different
things that are pushing
uh the kind of alternate browser world
in this direction
and that's really the wave that we're
writing in order to get in
um and that's what's going to allow you
know users tens of millions even
hundreds of millions of users
to be able to use this stuff in 2021 um
but then
when will it be native in chrome that's
probably going to be once we have once
we have
you know millions of cool websites
absolutely
what's the uh the most interesting use
case you've seen so far in the
decentralized web that you're excited
about
so one thing that people are working on
a lot right now
is this idea of having a domain name
controlled
by a group of people like by a dao
instead of by an individual and the
reason why this matters is because
admins have liability so
if you control your domain name inside
of godaddy and you're the admin you're
the one in charge
you can make a mistake make an update um
you could get hacked any number of other
problems and you also have legal
responsibility
and so for a lot of projects that are
trying to be you know
open source uh community driven
uh they still have this admin problem
for their website they still have all
the liability comes back to whoever
is building that front end and if they
can go all the way to
have that front end on the decentralized
web and have the domain name controlled
by a thousand people in the community
that are voting on its contents
you've actually changed the change the
legal framework
so that's one really cool one that a lot
of people are working on
uh another one is uh charging for
content you know
just pay me a dollar pay me two about
two dollars to watch this video
um the most basic type of content
monetization that just doesn't work in
the regular
in the regular internet do you think
that's going to become prevalent
do you think that's where we're going to
end up here on the internet for
monetization
i think there's i think it's a strategy
it won't be a strategy in
in every single case i think we're going
to have a lot of different things you
know
like right now we're kind of in the i
guess probably the bundling phase
of uh you know of content where you know
you go and you pay
you know netflix and then they give you
a million different things or you go
and you pay you know cable and they give
you a million different things
it's heavily bundled you're not able to
pay for specific content
so you can remember the name of the guy
who said this um
but it's pretty famous startup quote
that everything in startups everything
in technology is either bundling or
unbundling
and it's the simplest idea that's
actually very profound
and i think this is true so i think the
the short answer is everywhere where
it's previous where it's currently
bundled we'll probably see unbundling
and everywhere where it's currently
unbundled we'll probably see bundling
and one of the places where we see a lot
of bundling right now is on like video
content
and therefore that leads me to believe
that there is a huge demand for people
to unbundle it you know like
maybe maybe you have some premium
content that you'd want to sell
and you could charge you know five bucks
for a video rather
than having advertisements and not to
say that advertisements are
uh are a bad strategy or that you're
going to give up on it entirely but
there may be places where
um you know where it's appropriate to
charge
absolutely it's um it's so fascinating
to kind of think through micropayments
and streaming payments right kind of uh
rather than pay your 10 12 bucks to
netflix every month
what if you just pay kind of as you
watch things
and then at some point it tops out and
you pay
the 12 bucks right you know and there's
kind of a cap on how much you can spend
for power users or something it just
feels like that's kind of the
world that we're moving towards
obviously we need the tech stacks built
we need people to kind of
put the interfaces on there and get
users but it definitely feels like that
technology will uh will unlock a lot of
new business models one other thing i
like about
the content category in the
decentralized web it's just making it
easier
for people to post the content in a way
that it won't get you know it won't get
messed with it won't get taken down
youtube has been doing all kinds of
all kinds of things to you know crypto
content um and even just have the option
of
easy donations um because you know i've
seen this you know with influencers
where you essentially have this
like pent up demand amongst their
community where they're saying like
we think you're awesome we would like to
pay you
you what you're giving us primarily is
for free so we're looking for ways to
pay you
so maybe you sell me like a mug with
your face on it or something that's like
a common solution is
that influencers go and do a little bit
of e-commerce but maybe it's even more
natural to just say
you know donate to me i mean that's like
the patreon model almost
so you'll start to see i think a lot of
optional payments too
uh to influencers and and that could
wind up being a really big revenue
source i mean there were
early examples of this on the internet i
think there was one where um
this is probably like ah man i'm gonna
sound old it was probably 2005 or
something like that
where radiohead released an album and
the cost was
optional pay anywhere from zero to
whatever you want and they made millions
um
and and i think that you're gonna see
things like this
um from content creators where as long
as it's easy to pay me
then i can even have like a pay what you
absolutely couldn't agree more and uh i
think patreon and a couple of others you
know have done a centralized world but
it's uh it's coming
and uh and there might not be a
middleman it's uh it's a good way to
look at it
uh brad listen thank you so much for
taking the time to do this where can we
send people to find you on the internet
and find out more about unstoppable
domains so i would check us out on
twitter at unstoppableweb
you'll see all of our updates from there
um and then of course
you know check out ensembledomains.com
you'll be able to see what's um
see what the latest is um and we're
always
you know bro we're always shipping
something absolutely
and uh i'll throw you one softball to
end this uh every time i do the ad read
uh i try to emphasize this as much as
possible but i figured you'd be better
than me
uh i don't think that people get if
somebody else buys the domain
it's not there for them anymore like
there's only one it's very similar to
kind of urls in the centralized world so
maybe just talk a little bit
uh about the the kind of auction process
or the purchasing process of the actual
domains to end us
so what's happening is uh when you
purchase a domain
it is getting minted uh minted on the
blockchain and then sent to your wallet
so the way that the contracts work the
application works on the blockchain
you can only have one of each domain so
if the domain already exists
it can't be minted uh somebody else
already has it
and if you want to get it from them i
would recommend checking out openc
which is the secondary market where a
lot of people are trading uh trading
domain names
absolutely listen thank you so much for
taking the time to do this
everyone go check out
unstoppabledomains.com you can go get a
domain name
you can use it for everything from
hosting content on the decentralized web
to doing crypto payments i've got
pomp.crypto
none of you losers can get that one but
uh you can go get other ones so go uh go
check it out and uh thanks so much brad
we'll do it again
thanks so much for having me